2017 is shaping up to be a great year for
movies, with a ton of cool films already on
the schedule.
In fact, so many great movies are coming out
next year, we thought you might need a jump
start on planning.
Here's a look at the movies you won't want
to miss in 2017.
Winter
February was once the dumping grounds for
Hollywood's biggest failures.
But in 2017, the action heats up with the
long awaited big-screen adaption of Stephen
King's Dark Tower series, starring Idris Elba
as the iconic Gunslinger.
How awesome is that?
And if that wasn't enough, the dark knight
returns once again with the Lego Batman Movie.
Maybe this time he can finally save his parents.
"Where's the seat belt?"
"The first lesson is, life doesn't give you
seat belts!"
Spring
In March, you can look forward to Kong: Skull
Island, which brings the legendary ape forward
into the 1970s for a showdown with Samuel
L. Jackson and Tom Hiddleston.
Meanwhile, superhero fans will get the next
installment in the seemingly neverending series
of X-Men films with yet another Wolverine
flick.
But the biggest film of the spring is undoubtedly
April's Fast 8, which reunites everyone's
favorite multi-cultural team of rebels with
an equally sleek and sexy array of fast cars.
American filmmaking at its absolute peak!
Summer
In May, Marvel's hotly anticipated space romp
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 2 sets the
tone for a summer of fantastic sequels, including
follow ups for Pirates of the Caribbean, World
War Z, Kingsman, Transformers, Cars, and Despicable
Me.
But they're all overshadowed by the June arrival
of Wonder Woman, which finally brings one
of the world's greatest superhero to the big
screen in the movie event of the year.
DC's film efforts have a pretty poor track
record with the critics so far, but Wonder
Woman looks like it may finally change all
that.
Awesome.
So does Marvel have an answer for Wonder Woman?
Of course: it's your friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man.
"I'd love to keep this up but I've only got
one job here today and I've gotta impress
Mr. Stark, so, I'm really sorry.
Ah!"
July's Spider-Man: Homecoming is the first
Spidey film produced by Marvel Studios as
part of their shared cinematic universe, so
it will be interesting to see how it plays
out.
And if you're feeling burnt out on superhero
films and sequels, don't worry, because July
also brings legendary director Christopher
Nolan's gritty new war drama Dunkirk.
Fall
In August, Ridley Scott returns with the newest
piece of the Alien universe with Alien: Covenant,
which, despite its title, is actually a sequel
to 2012's Prometheus.
And another Ridley Scott sci-fi epic gets
a sequel with the follow-up to 1982's Blade
Runner.
Nobody has any idea what to expect from it,
but whether it's awesome or a total train
wreck, you definitely won't want to miss it.
Holidays
Three massive blockbusters anchor the 2017
holiday movie season, so you know exactly
what to ask Santa for next year.
November starts with the release of Thor:
Ragnarok, which also features the Hulk.
November continues with DC's answer to the
Avengers, Justice League.
"I've heard about you, didn't think you were
real."
"I'm real when it's useful."
But as big as both of those movies are guaranteed
to be, both will be dwarfed by the December
15 release of one of the most highly anticipated
films of all time, Star Wars: Episode VIII.
Will Luke actually talk this time?
We can't wait to find out.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
movie you're looking forward to most in 2017…